(audience applauds)
Sitting here with Paul
Reubens, we're back.
Were you, I'm very curious because,
I'm curious what you were like as a child.
Whenever I meet a performer
who's particularly interesting
or unique, I think, what was
that person like as a child?
Were you Pee-Wee as a child?
To a degree, I was.
[Conan] Yeah.
This'll sort of illustrate
who I was as a kid.
I was probably five or six years old.
I had a younger sister
a year younger than me.
I have a younger sister,
And she got for her birthday or Christmas
or something one time,
she got a little tea set,
which she was like, (gagging)
I don't want this tea set.
I, me, I was mesmerized by
the tea set, immediately.
I was like, you don't
want this, are you insane?
What is wrong with you,
ya know. (audience laughs)
You can serve miniature tea with this.
Yeah, and I mean, and it was that thing.
It was like a little cup,
this big.
Sure.
And so I like, freaked out when I saw it
and I was like, I'll take
it, you know, I'll take it.
And my Dad noticed that
and my Dad went like,
why don't we have a tea party, Paul?
My Dad had never said anything
like that to me before.
I was like, are you kidding me?
Like, you wanna have a tea party?
(audience laughs)
Give me three minutes, you know?
I ran upstairs to my room,
I had like, you know,
little kid furniture,
like a little chair.
Sure.
And a little table and stuff, so I went
and filled up the tea pot
and set out like a little,
little, what do you call it?
Saucer, I'm getting so excited
just thinking about it.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughs)
And, my Dad came up
and he sat down on the little chair
and he did the coolest thing,
I poured him a cup of,
you know it's water.
Right, right.
I poured him a little thing.
in a little teacup and he put
it up and he blew, he went.
(audience laughs)
That's nice.
And I thought, I have the
coolest Dad in the world
that he would like pretend, the tea.
(audience applauds)
So.
[Conan] That's nice.
So he drank the tea down,
and then he went, this
tea is unbelievable!
(audience laughs)
Who made, you made the tea?
I was like, yeah, I made, ah.
(audience laughs)
(Conan laughs)
So he like he drank three cups.
Right, right.
So he emptied the pitcher
and said Is there more tea?
'Cause if I don't have anymore
tea, I'm gonna freak out!
I have to have more tea!
Right.
So I ran,
filled the pitcher up, came back,
three more cups, it only,
three cups was all it took.
So, three more cups, delicious tea.
Paul, is there anymore tea?
Yeah, there's more tea!
I ran and got, finally after four trips,
to fill up the thing, I came back,
I said Dad, no more tea,
I'm sorry, we're out of tea.
And he said, what do you
mean, we're out of tea?
I said, the toilet's empty!
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
True, true story.
(Conan laughs)
What a wonderful.
Go ahead, have some!
Delicious!
Ya like it, huh?
Ya know, I'm just curious, I mean,
I know it's been a while since
you, your Pee-Wee Herman,
but have you ever thought
about getting back into
the Pee- Wee suit and being Pee-Wee again?
You know, I just finished a Pee-Wee movie,
a script for a Pee-Wee movie.
Right.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Thank you!
'Cause you look, you
look like you've, skinny,
you look like you stayed
in pretty good shape, and--
I've been trying to slim
down, shed a few pounds.
'Cause you know, we get older,
and gain a little bit of weight.
Right, do you think you could get, fit,
into the Pee-Wee outfit?
No, I don't think so.
No, 'cause we actually,
we actually found a Pee-Wee outfit.
Ah, ha, ha, ha, ha.
This is the real Pee-Wee Herman
outfit we have right here
and we were curious if
you would fit into it.
Do you think he could fit
into it? (audience cheers)
No, I can't.
Come on, give it a try!
Beg me!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
He's gonna fit right onto this,
it's gonna be fine.
I'll put the top on
and David Lee Roth can put the jacket on.
(audience laughs)
It's not gonna fit, you
wanna bet any money on this?
Yeah, I'll bet you $800.
Huh.
We have it, producer will pay it,
I don't have that kind of money.
I haven't gained that
much weight, but, they,
they were, it was, tight
to begin with, right?
Just really, yeah, it
was a very skinny suit.
(audience laughs)
(audience member catcalls)
(audience applauds)
Just.
(audience cheers)
(laughing) Got a little--
That's chaps, Pee-Wee chaps.
(Conan laughs)
(audience laughs)
Hey.
(audience member catcalls)
Yeah.
Do you feel yourself
becoming Pee-Wee
as you put it on?
You know,
you know, it's not about the pants.
Pee-Wee is really, in me.
Yeah, right.
You know?
(audience member whooping)
Yeah!
Little stage music here please?
("Tequila")
(audience cheers)
"Pee-Wee's Playhouse" airs
Monday through Thursdays
at 11:00 on Cartoon Network's Adult Swim!
Paul Reubens everybody!